all right so if you see my face changing
different colors here cuz the sun's just
but I said we do this like Brad be logs
I mean whatever uh we're not doing it in
a car yeah that's true um so okay we got
Legend of Korra we got beginnings part 1
and part 2 and though I think they
should have called it something
different I think it should have been
titled about time yeah I mean I
guess this is a little bit better oh I
don't know as like no it's like holy
was they really good just sitting
on this for like six seven episodes like
what the citizens III don't know so
where are we but yeah it's like yeah may
was this like so freaking good I mean
this was it really felt like the
original avatar shows but on top of that
it's like you get the origin of of where
the avatar started and the spirit world
and all this great stuff and it doesn't
feel like hey we're just it for like a
better you know I like the movie it
doesn't feel like The Hobbit where it's
like hey look that thing you gotta
recognize it it's very much hey this
really explains everything I mean this
it's not just a gimmick it's actually a
good story on its own even this didn't
connect to avatar at all it's still a
solid story it's still really really
good and yeah actually when I come back
to Korra house are like oh well you know
it's funny cuz I get a lot of flack uh
people keep saying well she's a teenager
well what do you expect well what kind
of stories that that this is like this
is how you take and the Aang see cuz
like this guy the for one the first
avatar he's a douchebag when it starts
off a jerk go to be fair he's stealing
food for his friend no but you know
what's not feeding a judge to him yeah
we're not a man bare pig ya know but
he's dealing the fire he's gonna use it
for his own needs you know a starting a
revolution you know just more for
himself but he he learns and that and
that
great that in the first season Dora did
learn and then it's like yeah it's icy
he learned his lesson and then he's
stuck with that big Joanie I'm trying so
something goes so far because if that
were the case then shouldn't we be
singing the praises of Anakin Skywalker
is one of the greatest characters ever
written why he's a teenager therefore
that no it's there's a good and a bad
way to write this stuff it hasn't been
awful but it's been a little mad this
season I think that argument actually is
insulting to teenagers to say uh how's a
teenager it's like no you know a
teenager's yes there's every age is
gonna have you know a con but there's a
lot of pros and one of the things is
that you know teenagers do work evil
baby
she's been sheltered you don't get it
she's been sheltered therefore she can
be boring that yeah
doesn't work that well this guy shelters
he's living in a shack
yeah wait uh uh with tribu me oh but I
get the like a number of people in
asking walls this is this what you want
I'm like well yes absolutely and this is
a great episode but it also really just
nailed how slowed this season has been
cuz I'm like wow in one hour they gave
us an angsty sort of character who went
through a whole journey and
transformation and it's taken us a
season and a half yeah I feel I'm out
there with Cora I feel like I watched a
season or something yeah
felt like like this was like the silver
iliyan or something like that like I
just saw this great big epic story and
it had everything in it interesting
characters it had this great arc it had
so much information about like the
spirit world and the human world and so
much information and it may was this it
told us everything we've been needing to
know for six episodes now and like it
did really effectively and really like
I'm kind of like I'm wondering again
it's like should this episode of run
first or yeah yeah bit I don't know I
don't but I mean I'm very happy I like
I'm really interested to see it's like
now that Cora has seen this whole story
will this have
yeah literally when she woke up and she
was like I'm Cora I'm the avatar
seriously sounded shouted like good now
do something like it yeah
act like an avatar learn something you
know just yeah I'm really hoping that I
mean it looks like they didn't do the
amnesia thing that much is more just an
excuse to get this back story but Oh
Wyatt
I'll buy ya cuz they owe such a good
back story I guess it's a but
it's not something that we were really
like oh we need an amnesia story so yeah
I mean it's just I'm really hoping
this'll like have an effect on her
because this was such a good episode at
the same time if there's little to no
Korra in it so it's not like okay well
we're back on track well no we're given
the story from something totally
different in a sense but it's great and
well it does well tie into everything
really well I'm sure it will because I
mean it did give us the whole backstory
now I'm wondering is bought to
influencing una log is unalaq actually
secretly working for raava or thinks he
is is bought to influencing it maybe
death
somebody came up with a good theory and
I don't think they're gonna go visit I
was like maybe like Lin beifong acts
like she's taking stupid pills and
everybody else is acting like an idiot
because vaatu now is influencing them
like I died I thought early doubtful but
I mean that'd be cool but I mean maybe
now this is all gonna come together and
be connected what I'm hoping and the
nice thing is that there is what I'm
hoping they'll do to you know maybe
address why Korra has been such a pain
this season you know or repeat at least
is that you know this guy this Juan
character went through this too that he
did start off with kind of a jerk and
kya yeah like I like that connection and
I'm hoping it's really the first season
instead of like and I'm still hang out
what Y rope what did we need to see in
the first season that bears any meaning
here we still wick amorous character
yeah with Korres character yeah
yeah well even where did Tenzin in the
Family Guy that they just completely
address around a mixture um but what and
whether or not toy lost my thought you
got it um great that's damn I had
something I liked the well they they
brought back all the Asian influenced
elements I like the physical
manifestation of yin-yang with raava and
vaatu and Benny lava and Klaatu barata
nikto and yeah that's idea so you get to
that big fight at the end it's like the
biggie yang they did the same thing and
we start with the two fish I'm always
like okay that's Portland ugh just
shouted subtle dose at all no I like the
original one where they were fighting
yeah like that they were sort of in the
shape of the yin-yang when they were
fighting um
right light now is more clever wasn't
quite as obvious you know all of them my
only thing is I don't know I'm gonna
have to check out the ending to the
original series again but they may be
playing a little loose with the
mythology here because I thought the
lion turtle said at the end of the
person was like before the elements
humans were mastering the energies and
themselves or something and I swear to
god I'm watching this it was like now
there's getting it all from Lion Turtles
is uh I I don't know it seems like
there's a bit of a disconnect but if
that's my biggest complaint yeah that's
not there's no freaking midi-chlorians
here oh yeah I'm era I was gonna say the
what actually is the one part I got a
little confused she's like I had to
close the gate before the end of the
world I guess I got a little confused
like is that the bad spirits gonna come
back and make this money convergence
yeah like what
garageband ever I didn't quite get what
that was like they even into the
backstory on the door swings both ways
when the planets all aligned Gozer comes
though now there's a North Pole and
South Pole and the door is open and
there's some sort of connection you saw
that with the two portals in and there
was a tree in the middle and when that
happens I guess one or the other could
take over if they're not in balancers I
mean I didn't quite get that part yeah
see that's why why should we take down
the orbit when the planets align there
is the chance for a ship to go down okay
and you want everything in Belper shore
last ten thousand years of darkness dogs
and cats living together mass sister
okay that's why the big bad spear was
like oh this time I'm gonna win cuz it
was the ten thousand years as gay okay
now I see okay and now it's coming
around again I liked their out to where
he's just like well that's not too bad I
mean if you like can never be destroyed
then you'll just come back to them oh ya
know in the grand scheme of things
everything is fine everything stays in
balance
it's just bad for you humanity will be
wiped out yeah oh I like in this 10,000
years of darkness they just uh yeah I
like that too I like I thought that was
a good way of being white because I was
like well wait if light and dark can
never be defeated like oh well you can
still just totally like
obliterate the planet for ten thousand
years and then light eventually will
come back like after a volcano might
still come out of here yeah um well not
but here's the again in this backstory
you get but when he's fighting the big
bad spirit at the end I mean you kind of
get it if he wins all darkness is gonna
roll on stuff like that and it's just so
simple so quick and you got it and then
going back to the the core one I have to
admit I'm still like we have to close
the portal whatever I'm like because of
who or what is it Tarlac 2.0 who's going
to like do something bad in there it's
like I'm still confused what is going to
happen
faith it's still a little confusing do I
use the what termina everything Noland
this it's just told out of order or
something actually Noland films I follow
easier in the way it's just not put
together very well I good story here
it's
like you know after seeing bad now it's
like I am Alex or Siva story you're
trying to tell ya but I'm like but we
had to sit through six episodes of
really meandering around that I'm like
there was a better way to display this I
think I mean well you know what I'll
reserve funny yeah I mean it's not done
I mean what we'll see what so so far I
yeah I'm kind of with you I'm like it
it's a good story I think I get what she
needs to do now but it's like why was it
told this way yeah and like I said I
mean I'm still not sure what evil and
how it's going to happen
we still has none of the motivations for
any of the villains we know I mean
Varrick being a villain okay that's cool
baby this one amazed what was he going
to know that's like we need to close the
doors what's he gonna do that's going to
make things so bad my guess is he's
being influenced by vaatu everybody's
kind of ridiculous I made this far too
maybe I'll be reviewing I mean because
if you think about it war I mean he was
saying he's like war power aggression
you know these things feed me you know
so maybe May but yeah but even just from
a basic story hey we had to stop acts
like even though there might be a
Twitter like again with Amon it's like
we knew why we had to stop him and what
he was doing you know here it's like
just something Bad's gonna happen might
mean 10,000 years start but we don't
know why or how or and if you want to
keep the characters motivations hidden
cuz I mean I'm not gonna disagree that
it's kind of cool that we're just like
okay maybe Coronel has to decide maybe
you know Luck's not a villain maybe he
is me you know maybe Varrick like we
don't yeah but it's tough to find an
interesting way to tell that up until
this point because we've waited six
episodes and it's kind of been like an
exercise in patience from a show that I
do genuinely like but it's still kind of
like you keep checking your watch like
okay really ya know this one I mean I
was totally invested I I just loved it
so um the only animation yeah oh god the
style and the
crowns and stymie justice it was a
different look and it really worked it
was like a it was very a Japanese uh
ukiyo-e paintings yeah I mean it would
block like uh what are their names if
you like this style of animation look up
to artist Hokusai and Hiro she gay they
did nothing but stuff like this and
watching it it seemed really clear to me
that that was their main influence there
may have been some Chinese in there too
but a lot of it seemed like he or she
gay and hokusai and the wave the giant
tsunami way that everybody sees it like
a Japanese sushi bar yeah like every way
to go soon yeah so look them up because
it very much was that except for the
clouds which seemed like something out
of Secret of Kells but yeah what a lot
even like the layout of the site on the
turret almost Kassie gonna cows - yeah
but I like that it was basically like he
does she gave woodblock combined with
like Secret of Kells like their own sort
of style and oh my god spirit away with
all the spirits going to the man yeah
somebody watched is somebody watched a
few Miyazaki movies so everything I'll
say just to maybe give credit to another
movie and Princess Mononoke - I got yeah
we go you're down by my estimate yeah um
the favorite thing I'll give credit to
is that the lemur in this episode is
really cool and you remind me a lot of
well Dafoe from that John Carter movie
that everyone's like yeah I'm the one
guy who saw it and it's not as bad as
everyone says like it's not good but
it's it people were way too mean on that
film and he just reminded me you haven't
seen it either so you shouldn't talk I
don't I want to be associated if people
are just like you like John Carter with
hell no for a dull ass action film I
thought was fine I don't know the books
or anything I'm sure they're better but
no comment no printed just done this
action feel and I really like the won't
Defoe character in there and I haven't
seen a character like that supportive of
that interesting and that tough and
strong and funny and stuff uh and this
is a character very similar to that I
like those kind of characters I mean
it's really just giving goblin tip Lemur
character I thought he had a really
clear but all these characters are
really clear ok I will say this I have
not liked the animation as much in this
season they switch Studios I liked the
first season style more that being said
and that's not really the studio's fault
it's just different styles of doing
things so that being said like this is
like a Redemption episode because this
episode was so brilliantly animated the
the animation hasn't bothered me it has
an other Drudge no you doesn't kill the
show for me but I do when people talk
but I'm like yeah I do like season ones
animation where they do the spiritual
stuff and so the flatter stuff and the
stylistic stuff much better than the
realistic stuff and so when we get an
episode like this it just shines and it
yeah look via and whatever the spirits
come up they shine too but we have so
little them you know until now that you
know I think it's why he hasn't had a
chance to really bloom hello I love the
ending - it's like this will be my job I
will be the avatar and bring peace to
the world cut to his like cores oh wow I
feel okay I know humanity sucks but I
like that baby they turned him into like
a bodhisattva or you know they turn him
into like a Buddha character as to keep
reincarnating and coming back until
Humana I until he's able to enlighten
all souls and unlike them that was cool
it added a lot to the mythos and I guess
I don't think I was missing the mythos
that much because I liked season 1 just
fine and there was very little of the
actual mythos in it yeah I mean look
this one's just been missing something
pretty much since episode once it's been
missing the spirits and here's yet
yeah it's like I'm kind of God - we got
our third episode in a season cold
spirits that's more points that's that
would have been the other name of the
Zemzem The Legend of Korra gets to the
point so yeah well we love the man so uh
hopefully we'll see you at the next one
hey Carrie